vecchi nero a fargli sentire la grande
volta
[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti ragazzi come state
belle 200 euro questa felpa sperduto
regole standard di shock a roma perché
allora voi non lo sapete ma quando devi
segnare nella porta di rocket league
il gioco si chiama stop tar
io non ho parole ma il pallone la rocket
sostituito con un pallone da spiaggia
più leggero dai pace non ho mai fatto
allora che a soli oggi vi racconto una
storiella che secondo me vi fa vi fa
ridere di raccolta più note mi sono
ubriacato allora glielo te questa cosa
non la volevo dire io questo video non
lo volevo fare però mi ritrovo a dover
raccontare questa roba perché merita e
ve la racconto queste si chiama la
storia ha un nome questa storia questa
storia si chiama la guerra di borgo dora
faccia sono me strano sembrati un po
sembrati con avventura del signore degli
anelli prove la prima volta che mi sono
bloccato allora avevo mi sono piegato
molto tardi abbiamo sa perché io sono ho
scoperto di essere astemio quella volta
lì allora non è mai piaciuto ad alcuni
non bevo non sono persona che invece se
beve prende una birre tina quando sono
con gli amici un coctail eno ma non vado
giù in discoteca a malmenarli per
alcolici perché non sono non sono magro
anche quindi sta roba non mi aiuta però
non sono proprio il tipo che che beve
rombi non bevo non fumo non bevo non
spendi i miei soldi che cosa devo fare
per ora questo preferiamo in un altro
video di queste cose
andiamo avanti avevo 19 anni era il mio
compleanno
ok stavo con la mia prima ragazza
la ragazza che con la quale ho fatto
anche i video su youtube che gli trovato
ancora niente eravamo a torino c'era un
mio amico che si era appena
se appena lasciato si era lasciato da
pochissimo quando un tuo amico si lascia
in genere va in discoteca ci vive
proprio fa la residenza in discoteca
questo qua organizzava una serata anche
il martedì il mercoledì dove tutti i
giorni anche quando c'è la scuola perché
perché c'era voglia di venti di andare
in discoteca no mio compleanno cadeva di
sabato perfetto detto ah beh dai ciò che
andiamo in discoteca non ho mai fatto
coprendo in discoteca la mia vita mai
però andiamo non faccio organizzativi
fai fai fai tu hanno suonato a questo
nemico gli ho detto allora fai tu ti
invita fai tu e lui fa ci penso io
tra l'altro io ero già non
conosciutissimo ma avevo già quando è
che è successo sta roba aprile mia 14
quindi avevo tipo quasi un milione di
iscritti verrà tra l'altro avevo 700mila
e quindi ero già comunque conosciuto
capitolo vabbè andiamo andiamo i veri e
stata una serata da un rischiato tutto
la carriera la vita la famiglia a
qualsiasi dagli amici
andiamo a serata non avevo mangiato
molto è facciamo una premessa perché in
genere quando tu bevi e non mangi tanto
senti molto di più alto perché il cibo
non assolve quindi un casino entriamo
discoteca ci sediamo avevamo un nostro
tavolo però motivo in sei o sette
insomma i miei amici arriva il mio amico
quello che ho organizzato tutto tutto
quanto perché number one e inizia a
versarci da bere no avevamo della vodka
alla pesca
mi ricordo ancora serve la vodka alla
pesca quella roba lì la serata inizia
beh come avuto sto bicchiere qua poi non
mi ritiro dopo che ho bevuto
da quel momento lì io mi ricordo solo e
soltanto alcune cose che in un unico
perché ovviamente per quanto benvenuti
conti niente ecco io da quel momento da
quando avuto quel bicchiere solo quello
non è che ho bevuto solo quel bicchiere
o bevuto
ho iniziato a vedere la gente a scatti
se nel senso che la gente la quando
larga nei giochi ugual giuro su dio non
mi è mai successo incredibile nella mia
vita non è mai successo ma un mio
compagno parlava e gli usciva l'audio in
ritardo adesso in editing faccio vedere
che cosa intendo
lory come stai ti stai divertendo io ve
lo giuro quanto è vero iddio che io sta
cosa qua la posso replicare solo in
editing perché non mi e mai più successo
nella mia vita di vedere qualcuno che
parla di sé dive di sentirli l'audio in
ritardo la gara brava la cava di un
secondo c'è un ping altissimo c'era sul
mio amico parlava mi dice valori tutto a
posto perché io ero seduto sul divano e
guardavo gli altri che si divertivano e
c'erano che mi parlava e oggi arriva in
ritardo quindi li ho detto a cavolo ma
quindi è così che ci si sente doppiati
ma che situazione brutta mamma mia non
mi piace neanche insieme a quello
iniziato a vedere doppio e da lì se
iniziate le cose le comiche non so
neanche come descrive le porco demonio
sbagliato a porta vuota è successo
allora iniziamo a ballare ballare tra
visto su just dance come ballo vi va beh
eravamo io e la mia ragazza balliamo
insieme questo pani parlava arriva
ritardo tutti contenti tutti felici buio
totale o da quel momento un black out
dopo il black out flash momento in cui
mi ricordo ci sono amico che mi dice
lori ma se non ti senti bene andiamo a
casa
e io no no no tutto a posto nella mia
testa suonava così no no no no tutto a
posto a posto dai secondo me era tipo
così poi buio di nuovo i flash che ciò
subito dopo passano non so tot minuti
stiamo ballando sul divano tutto voglio
di nuovo flash che ciò la mia ragazza mi
sta prendendo a schiaffi per tentare di
svegliarmi anche lei era molto ubriaco
in quel momento quindi lei stava ridendo
e le mentre che rideva mi darà gli
schiaffetti in faccia e vabbè lasciamo
perdere che saluto magari era meglio non
dire la parole luglio totale flash di
dio che sto semi vomitando arrivata non
sta vomitando dentro un secchio quello
dove metti le bottiglie aveva andato non
l'avevo comitato ma qualcosa era uscito
fuori è un secondo dopo quel secchio
finiti in testa a nichi il ragazzo con
cui iniziato a fare video questa non è
una storia inventata ragazzi io io
questa storia non la volevo raccontare
però minitro min
la gente mi ci parlare della mia vita io
lo faccio e poi sembra che dico balle no
ragazzi
buio totale di nuovo flash un mio amico
mi sta tenendo il braccio sinistro e
l'altro col braccio destro di cui in
guerra e mi stanno trascinando fuori e
mi dicono da lorenzo
con un gradino che ce la fai bravo così
un cretino che ce la fa il buio di nuovo
flash ci sono io per terra sdraiato sul
marciapiede e uno di questi due miei
amici mi fa così dai loro i sei
tranquillo che l'ambulanza sta arrivando
so che faccia avete fatto perché tutti
fanno questa faccia quando racconto
questa storia le feste di vento l'anima
della festa quando la racconta
incredibile buio molto più grande di
tutti gli altri mi sveglio alle sei e
mezza del mattino in ospedale con delle
flebo attaccate alle braccia e mio padre
davanti perfetto questa è stata la prima
volta che mi sono beccato il mio padre
avanti è stato al parco di classe ma non
è finita qui che vi sembrava allora io
vi ho raccontato questa cosa dal mio
punto di vista però c'è uno dei miei
amici che stavano con me non sono andato
in coma etilico c'è andato un altro mio
amico che stava messe in sei più o meno
erano i miei amici
uno di questi era messo peggio di come
l'ho messo io cosa è successo sto mio
amico mi hanno citofonato ragazzi in
questo video c'è anche gianpi e tirate
questo finendo sono in chiusura ma devo
fare una cosa 15 titolo nella storia in
base a quello che sento felice il verde
di me no ecco un'altra che devo
affrontare un altro leader insieme a me
quindi vi ripeto c'era questo anche mio
amico che si è ubriacato anche lui
ok che ci si ricordi di lui la sa perché
io sono sempre l'anima della festa
onorevole quando si sta arrivando giusto
rimasto celato mio amico e che anche non
aveva bevuto un sacco non faccio nomi
ovviamente a un certo punto ero
all'ospedale mi son svegliato alle sei e
mezza
come vi ho detto questo mio amico era in
codice rosso in codice giallo lui era in
codice rosso e lui abbiamo andato in
coma etilico
un pesante mi sveglio che lascia stare
il discorso che mio padre abbiamo
risparmio accendo il telefono e vedo che
alle 5 del mattino mi è arrivato un
vocale da questa persona che stanno in
come ti dico detto ma poi impossibile
che abbia mandato di locale che sta
nell'altra stanza di fianco e nell'altra
stanza che è svenuto come ha fatto a
mandarmi vocale sta malissimo ma li
stava malissimo e quindi e quindi ho
detto books è successo
ve la spiego praticamente quando
uscivamo dal non non contenti del
discorso del dell'ubriachezza quando
siamo usciti dal locale c'erano degli
extracomunitari che rubavano i telefoni
della gente rubavano i telefoni ea me
non avevano rubato il telefono perché
nella tasca
avevo il power man quindi mi hanno
rubato il power bank pensando forse il
telefono quindi via telefono è l'unico
che si è salvato di tutta la gente
sversa che usciva la discoteca al mio
telefono è l'unico estasi si sono fatte
per un po di bottari però la gente
ubriaca monete erano ovviamente a tanta
gente ubriaca hanno trovato il telefono
compreso questo mio amico che ha il
codice rosso
quindi io mi sveglio la mattina alle sei
e trenta e mi trovo un vocale di questo
mio amico di circa 10 secondi che dà il
titolo la storia la storia si chiama la
guerra di borgo dora borgo dora e una
zona di torino però di capire vocale in
questione e io chiuderei quel vocale in
questione è questo qui lorenzo siamo i
carabinieri di borgo dora
se hai così il numero di questo
cellulare ha chiamato immediatamente ci
serve serve parlare con te ok
carabinieri borgo dora se si sentì il
suo messaggio chiama subito su questo
telefonici
[Musica]